Selam aleykum we're not going to lie
here what I care to when people try
understand Islam in a general sense
sometimes they can be let down by the
media they can be let down by
Islamophobes they can be let down by a
range of different people that talk
about Islam one thing that sometimes is
under emphasizes the fact that
non-muslims and Muslims alike are let
down by Muslims themselves they let down
by Muslims who misrepresent Islam in
both theory and in practice today we're
going to be consulting with one of the
most prominent Salafi diary or preachers
that has come to the United Kingdom and
has since then but being quite prominent
in Salafi communities Salafi meaning the
way of the Companions in his
interactions with other Salafis he's
encountered many groups fringe groups
sectarian type fringe groups who have
one could argue distort the image of
Islam in both theory and practice today
he's going to be describing to us his
experience with some of the main
scholars of such groups or some of the
main scholars are referenced by such
groups we will learn from this what he
thinks the difference between a
methodological salafism is and a group
Salafism this will be an interview
hopefully which will shed light on some
of the interactions between Salafis and
between each other not only that but
between seller fees and on seller fees
hopefully this will be of use to you and
of benefit to you
it's not like a who's lighter but
I care - I'm here with a war son that
that we share who has come from the
United States a prominent Indian Isis
dour and who's come to live in the UK
he's a graduate of Modena University and
has since then been very prolific in
selfie communities and interactions with
all kinds of selfies and we're here to
ask them questions generally about
Salafism but also more specifically
about some of his own interactions so
I'll go check oh yeah so sure I wanted
to ask you general before for our
viewers what you understand from the
term selfie and what is voice following
the certain you understand spinaroonie
left or salatu was-salam and also in
that first of all I want to extend a
warm welcome to how many job to my
community here in a Liverpool well I'm
at the hand and male lives our job put
your efforts of travelling from where
you came from all the way to here
putting your skills of good deeds from
Okayama same thing weight of not a
disclaimer but making things very clear
because I in the past did a few things
where I was giving advice to the
brothers who are following the way of SP
specifically and we're gonna deal with
these issues in Xalapa certain
publications yeah I always trying to
maintain decorum and respect because my
goal of my objective is not to fight
people yes my goal and my objective is
to make the Dawa of a set of here clear
to people to the best of my ability and
in trying to do that it becomes really
crucial that we have the etiquette of
what we're claiming work on which is
said of here as it relates to your
question a certain fear is the way that
a Muslim is going to practice his
religion the way that Allah has Maynard
and cometh upon everyone and what the
prophet sallallaahu sudden has advised
to it as well as an ayah before I'm a
lot of them mentioned they couldn't
I'm in cool I told women haja every
single group of people are big
communities every email we made for you
a Sharia halal and Haram legislation of
their way of life and we made for them
in Manoj the main Hajj is the way that
you go about practicing this religion
and the way that we go about practicing
the religion is what I was called to in
the Quranic commanded and what the
prophet sallallaahu seven has also
Illustrated and called to in commandment
that is following the way of the setup
of this woman the son of this Ummah
being at the top of the list the
companions may Liza generally be pleased
with all of them and then those people
were the students of the Companions
known as the tabie mean and then those
people were the students of the tabi
mean and also most people came after
them so clearly we include the great
scholars of Islam and mathematic and
Imam Abu Hanifa Imam Ahmed and Imam
Shafi all for them and other than that
all of them are from the people we call
and describe as the senate but at the
top of the list is following of ascend
the way the Companions do so what they
understood what Islam is it's what we
understand other stands the be made
after the worships that they did we do
the same thing but they didn't do we
under the read or the ayah the
celebrations that they did we do the
same thing so if there was something
that the Companions had the ability to
do at their time and they did not do it
we don't do it as as simple as that and
personally with my hood Cinnabun about
the Muslims all of themselves
I don't believe there is a single Muslim
walking on the face of the earth no
matter what is method is no matter what
it's must let is I don't believe that
there is a Muslim in his right mind
except that every Muslim is going to say
I don't have a problem with following a
little bucket or not with manna 90 may
Allah be pleased with them and what they
did is what we should be doing so what
happens is that a lot of things get lost
in translation
because many people call themselves
Sanofi they may not necessarily get a
good picture of what Senate fear is and
so then it becomes confused to other
people not selfie they complained
people's actions who are set a feud with
what Senate feeds and before you us the
next question I would just give this
example I'm a revert to this religion
and I'm african-american and the
community that I came from was a
community in which many Muslims came
into my community and took advantage of
my people
people were Pakistani people Indians
Afghanistan people were Arabs they came
into my community they so Hummer it's so
common they sold us pork they sold us
items that were out of date
they ripped us off some of it now when I
looked at them they didn't give a good
picture of what Islam was now a person
who may be Asian person who may be our
person maybe whatever he's going to look
at me he's going to say we don't accept
from you on who some if you said you're
going to reject and Liz Lemon because of
what those people used to do in your
community because they were not a
reflection of Allah slam they were
Muslims but they went out a reflection
about us man so I make that same point
we have to disconnect 70 people who have
a responsibility to live up to the name
as Muslims have a responsibility to live
up the name of the snack but we don't
always do that but I'm just talking for
people to understand don't reject the
truth because so and so or this one with
that one is not practicing the truth
this is something that al Islam rejects
and that's why I like Tyler mentioned
statement Allah yeah I mean I mean I
recommend full circle like I do human
ballet that didn't oh you are
responsible for your own selves to do
what's right to follow the truth it
doesn't hurt you if you do that those
who go astray so that's what Senate fear
is in a nutshell so is it fair to say
that really what you're describing is
Islam when you
in a sense that everything that a loss
of parallel to I like once and the
Companions did according to the way of
the prophet really is Islam so Salafism
your understanding and it's lamb are two
sides of the same coin no doubt about it
I said if he is an Islamic Mustafa an
Islam which is pure and diluted and it
is not contaminated with anything
it is a synonym for al-islam just as the
Sunnah is a synonym for price in Islam
the correct way and from Pattin Agia is
a synonym for price in Islam the correct
way so I said afiyah
shouldn't be understood to be something
else so we talk about things in an
intellectual way we have to make sure
that we make this very clear but it's
kind of like what the non-muslims make
the mistake with when we say Allah
we worship Allah we believe in Allah
sometimes non-muslims think a lot is
another guy other than the colic that
anybody worships so when we say Allah
they think we have our own guy unto
ourselves
no we're talking about and hodduk the
lord of the worlds Allah Allah and Allah
so son if he is the same way we don't
want people or people should not think
when we say said Afiya it's something
that is foreign something else no all it
is the definition following this
religion the way the first generation
followed this religion now will buckle
north man honey and the rest of those
campaigns may Allah be pleased with that
now a question I have is that there are
some groups that emerged many of them
very intolerant in different ways right
and that ascribe themselves to Salafism
they'll say I am a Salafi they'll say I
am following the way of the Sahaba some
of them were seeing overseas extremists
for example that do take fear and they
they also claim to follow the Sahaba in
our quarters here in this country in a
part of the west we see ultra intolerant
people like you mentioned like
for example the set of publications
people like that find it very difficult
to communicate or to cooperate with
other members of the Muslim community
how do we differentiate between salafism
as understood as a managed or as a way
if you like from the set of the group
all those individuals who ascribe to
sell abysm only is a really important
that knowledge it plays a really
critical role in this because if a
person has knowledge will be in a
position to realize this is not said
afiyah and that over there is not said
Afiya but if a person is ignorant it's
not in a position to discern can't make
a distinction
it'll just base it upon mere claims mere
claims so I think that's really critical
that people understand as a lot
mentioning before army gave this
comprehension as understanding to people
for in Menton bhima for in a new beam
environment will be defaulted Ethel
alas said to the prophets on a live
segment if the people believe the way
you and your companions believe and
those people with diving right so all we
have to do is know how and what was the
Prophet upon us of Allah what he was
senator so we know that the Nepean islam
some vital something was a gentle man he
was a gentle man he had a club he had a
dad he has suffered he was truthful he
was a person more than anything else who
had an even be glad without any
when we feel like that
so his Akiva his three bang what he
believed how he worshiped and his mother
with the people look at that then we say
anyone who's doing that that said if he
even if he doesn't call himself son of
you so I'm a person giving downward luck
I'm going to a message it I do not
believe this wedge it for me to go in
here beating the drum saying said it he
said I don't have to do that mmm-hmm I
don't have to do that and a person
doesn't have to even call himself sanity
Allah didn't reveal
make that wedding upon him so what we
have to do is we have to look at what
was the Prophet doing some love why he
was sending them what was he up on and
we say whoever is doing that then that
individual is on a set Athiya and if the
person is falling short of the mark
we don't exclude him and take them off
of a center fear we just say that he's
not reaching all of what should have
been reached and we're all falling short
of the mark
no doubt about that there is a
concentration nowadays on the scholars
of Saudi Arabia and one particular
scholar has become very prominent
especially in terms of the you know the
amount of followers that they've gotten
in terms of tough leads it's general
Adnan çelik and it's become almost like
a global movement now pockets of every
Muslim country have some followers who
follow this this ship almost in a blind
following former what do you have to say
about this and what were your kind of
experiences with chef's ability as a
relief to the brothers who were from the
West American that you came I don't
think any of the brothers were on the
scene right now have known a ship for
being longer than I because when I was
in and Medina I was close to the
Sudanese students and they were very
close to a ship or beer a chef Trevino's
me by my name for all of these years he
never said to the group of brothers who
claimed that they had this love for him
to the degree where we find this
although one of them was speaking they
were letters just as extrusion extremist
yet extremism and one lecture the person
was sit there you say chef Coby and chef
Coby and gonna be 100,000 times and
not mention Ola and not mention us love
so Malala who said this little they
claim that they love and honor and
respect and shall they do yeah but none
of them
a chef will be longer than I've known
him and the chef Robbie moved out was
and he is a style of the same because
other scholars have said that and as a
result of that we have to respect him
and he deserves that respect he's gained
that respect but although that is the
case we have to say the truth the truth
is the truth that's what we learned from
Sofia especially from the scholars who
we met in shampoo or be used to be upon
that and used to teach people that way
that really respect people but we found
principles we respect with respect
personalities but we've followed
principles we don't follow individual
people like that so as a relates to chef
Robi is no doubt a scholar of this
religion but a lot of people have they
may go overboard with the shaykh rabee
to the point then one of the ships of
these brothers and he was supportive of
Kerby and then medina right now his
name is a ship
I'm the recommended Dean he has a good
relationship in hama didn't know Heidi
who broke away from Sheikh for being
there having problems I share up the
memory a demon as a pushchair in the
Sunnah
he was formed and he was asked about how
some people had this extremism in chef
Rafi and he said you know some of these
people worship ship would be very
metaphorically man now had some other
person made this mistake about someone
else one example Shiva be said about
same boat over Louisville Louisville in
Louisville that same photo said that the
itch the Islamic societies are societies
of a jagiya and as a result of that some
people said that say they put a make
takfeer of the Muslims I won't believe
say multiples make interfere I think he
was speaking metaphorically back there
are things of jangly
meaning of the Muslim societies I don't
think it was making tech fear of
everyone but what happens is if you an
enemy to say the photo you take is worse
and even the worst possible
interpretation but if you were framed
I'm saying photo and you love him and
respect them you give the best
interpretation so a chef
I'm the right member nadine
metaphorically said these brothers
worship chef Robi he didn't mean that
their profile but had he been their
enemy they would say you see guys making
touch here
mmm signs me context here but anyway he
was pointing to the reality of many
prophets and that is that whatever shame
Kirby says that's what they're going to
say if he says it's ha ha ha ha
he says it's Haram Haram if he says no
Teddy Gupta
he says you okay okay he says your major
style your major scum he says you're
ignorant you're ignorant and that's what
lot of times referring to when selling
the Quran about the I don't kita it
turned like bam bam Houma batiment doing
it that they take their priests and the
monks as lords along with Allah I comedy
Jackie really important when I went to
Medina and the doors of the Santa Fe are
open for me and I was in Medina shape
where be was one of the people who
helped me to be on set a fear but one
thing that really Allah blessed me with
was that I was looking towards Jordan -
what an amount and then Benny was saying
and then I been here at Matalan I mean
he he has students like the Shahada how
to be a chef before Hudson right the
ship Hussein and Elijah and on and on
say demon Aladdin I was hot and Queenie
do love your son and Reuben and he has
many many students I have seen with my
own eyes our students who are close to
Ellen bang have refuted his positions
and his rulings on hadith and the band
would say the hadith is offended or died
his student will come and saying I
disagree with the ship and give the
opposite ruling I've seen that and that
was the dollar and the tape
bang it was the same teacher our email
and imam abu hanifa rahmatullah nanny
who said to his students student Abu
Yussef yes wait wait ah yeah I got poo
one too you don't write everything that
I say I say something today I make
change it tomorrow I'm a human being I
mean change my position don't probably
follow me like that so that's what I saw
with Ellen bang I will challenge you I
will challenge you and anyone who else
is listening
find me a situation with beans brothers
had disagree with shape for being
anything you're not gonna fight it just
as you won't find them retracting any
mistakes
mmm-hmm you won't find them retracting a
mistake that make mistakes we all make
mistakes the Prophet mention some about
why didn't say that many summer fun inja
weather's quiet will be successful as
long as you talk you're gonna make
mistakes
so you have to be willing to retract
your mistakes that's just what it is to
be human
show me where one of those brothers
retracted with the exception of brother
donut deep who said something that was
an extreme statement yes a that the Nama
they contact SP to find out who said it
be in the West and when that issue was
brought to some of the scholars in Saudi
Arabia and all of the scholars are not
only in Saudi Arabia but when that
statement of his was brought to some
long silence he retracted that publicly
that's the only retraction that I know
that came from any of those brothers and
I'm not saying don't what a diva's with
them right now but maybe I hope we get a
chance to talk about down at the Balu
later on but my point is a Sheridan bats
a shareable thing me Loretta marvelous
land a ship movement Rockets away you
will find their students refuting the
positions of all of us ships with edit
with good manners but you won't find his
brothers who follow shake forbid ever
saying the ship was wrong too
this was wrong for that which
brings me to this other issue if you
don't mind there was a time when the
study brothers were all together and we
were united on the heart of one man
although there were some differences but
we were all together as a money UK and
you can in America and they being a
mid-90s at the beginning said if he has
started taking off we were all together
and I remember the issue that caused me
to become public enemy number one to
them to this very day and had to do with
the extremism in shape are there some of
the brothers from the UK we had went
over to Saudi Arabia to do a seminar
knowledge based seminar I believe it was
called the elbow bucket acid dip seminar
or it could have been there in my
seminar it was those series I'm pretty
sure of a bucket a slug deep and the
brothers from Brixton and Luton were
having problems with the boolean of SP
trying to take over the Dow and so forth
so on
so I was one of the translators at the
seminar so the brothers from Wilton like
brother Abdul Kadir Bush they said we're
gonna have a meeting with Schecter of
beer to try to get some understanding as
to how to solve this problem amongst
ourselves so I said okay I'll come
I just went to be there it has nothing
to do with me I wasn't the Imam of
Brixton I wasn't connected to Luton and
I definitely wasn't with that speed so I
went as a translator a chef Bobby began
to lay into of the car the Bosch and
used to Satan was telling them you have
to go back and make peace and you have
to do this you have to do that and you
brothers but and he was really giving
him a goal for his money
and chakra be was very upset he was very
upset and then he made a statement that
I couldn't accept because I know it
wasn't true he said that the chefs from
Jordan Sheridan Harry the chef Salim
Akil am a chef Musa Nasser Akhmatova
Hari and a chef Osama at that time
animal oh he said that these people
along with Abu Hassan Marathi are trying
to take the attention of the Shabaab
away from the real Emma mean in him and
they caused him the chibok to look at
them and I said well what are you
talking about he said I'm the right man
Hernando Hispanic brother who had
extreme views back then very intolerant
back then very intolerant the reason why
I'm saying his name is because I have to
make it very clean he said I'm the right
man
Hernando called me and he told me that
these chefs supported someone who shaped
Ravi was not happy with their in America
our brother imam abu muslimah
- allahu taala baraja i said what do you
mean what do you mean he's a harem
a girl told me I said no
that's not true Hernando was not
practicing Islam any more even and
Hernando was known to be a person who as
in his narrations and subtractors
narrations and the man is not even
practicing separately after being very
upset and very animated when I told him
the reality of Hernando he calmed down
and he said I don't believe everything
that the Shabbat tell me when they
called me one minute he was very upset
and then when I told him the reality of
a commando he calmed down and said I
don't believe it everything but the
Shabbat tell me when they called me so I
saw that repeat was very upset over
here and in a few minutes he came down
over here so it made me feel this thing
is about designers with Abu Hassan Allah
be that's that it was how I feel fellow
so there was a brother happens I was
good friends with him at that time he's
one of the leaders of SV his name is
Musa Richardson and that time was a
balance brother at that time I used to
believe
that that brother when he goes back to
America is going to be really beneficial
because it has good social skills and he
was mature he was a good person anyway
he sent me an email to Maxie what
happened at the midges what happened
with the city with the share I told them
I'll tell you later when we talk but I
saw some things in the shin that don't
allow me to take everything that he says
so those brothers from SP put pressure
on Musa Richardson who was not lived
them really at that time but they put
pressure on them they will go on a witch
hunt at that time Musa Richardson gave
them my email as I did that said and
magister Amanda when you sit with people
in cinematic mm-hmm especially if the
canal is sensitive he gave them the
email I don't blame them because
pressure it burst pipes you know the
onion pipes if there's too much pressure
the primer bus so this is how it is but
that was how I became public enemy
number one they read that I saw his
won't be some things that won't allow me
to take everything that he has to say to
them that was disrespectful honest that
statement if you just look at it from
the face value I mean that's that's that
you can say that about any so it was
like the only one with Internet was
saying it what did you see what did you
see
and then thing we judge are you being
disrespectful all right but that's just
the point
to answer your question right that's the
rule and the extremism that we feel let
me find manifested in some of the
brothers as it relates to a ship for a
beer and ship would be doesn't deserve
that he doesn't deserve that type of
work so what you've mentioned is not
dissimilar from what dr. Baker mentioned
in some of his interactions as general
Granatelli in particular what he
actually mentioned to us in the
interviews that there was a particular
took place on a whole arbitration
process and that it was overturned like
he was saying from one kind of extreme
to another one agreement was overturned
after someone convinced it might be an
affiliate of a sudden thing so the
question I will ask you is if that is
the case and we know this of Cheryl
honey how is the way we should perceive
epidemic how should one have an
interaction with scholarship generally
but more specifically about ship about
honey
as we mentioned Shona B is a style no
doubt about that a scholar body and he
is a scholar who is respected for the
fill that he's in and and our religion
we make the table more than the sauce
and Allah says something in the Quran
with the Prophet said something so a lot
of them said APA is we take those two
sources and we glorify and we magnify
them so we had the statement of the
prophets on the lava egy the honey was
sedimentary lemma one of the two NBA the
scholars are the inheritors of the
prophets so if a ship would be is a
scholar or any other scholar for that
matter we have to raise them up
we'll have to respect them but we raise
them up to the degree that he deserves
there is a hadith and citing some in the
introduction in which I assure said well
Myrna and new medicine and nice Vanessa
know we've been commanded to people in
their proper places don't treat your
parents as if they're children and don't
treat the policeman as if he has no
authority and don't treat the husband as
if no we treat anybody in accordance to
the treatment that they deserve
so Sheikh maybe he deserves that but
although that is the case we just don't
go overboard and we look at the reality
I have seen with my own eyes I heard
with my own ears
things that I'm allowed me to take him
as the Imam of a doclet ideal and that's
not from the assume of the religion that
we love each other
each other I will summer and day I've
seen with my own eyes with my own ears
things I say no way I don't care if
mMmmm Benny said that I don't agree with
that because I have my own eyes and my
own ears on my own experience and also I
have history on my hand since I've been
here at Myrtle I ve made that statement
there are a lot of things that have
transpired that the amount of a giant
what ideal wouldn't say this wouldn't
judge people in this type of way and
then we had number three Shelby himself
saying I'm not comfortable with that I
am NOT the Imam of the Jacque with
deities piece of them yes he said that
that is you know from the licata
that's from his words he said I don't
accept that he said I am NOT the Eman
and then fourthly we have Scala singing
then a jaw with ideal doesn't even exist
right now
shut up the license raj in other than
that they were saying this is what we
have right now is liebe and Nima so from
what I saw with my own eyes in my own
ears is that incident with a black man
Hernando when the ship was saying one
thing one minute believing in that and
then when I told him it's not like that
Hernando he is that Hernando is not
practiced in the religion Hernando is
known for mubahala and being you know a
person who as on two marriages and takes
nine races away from the reality and
right away you calm down another issue
is when the elbow has a not only thing
was very very hot and I had loved the
respect firehouse in monarchy and I
still have love and respect so and just
before you go into that full of viewers
that you could say that cannot agree was
with
wrongfully at one point without about it
he was he respected him and I think doc
top didn't have to bake up yeah he moved
into that yesterday because it was mo
Hassan and Marathi yeah who sat with the
brothers and then called chef Rafi and
fact-check Robina said this is what I've
been agreed to and chevre be wrong
besides I'm on time that up sir to come
back and to break that kind of track
that's right that's what I experienced
yeah I'm gonna jump with the ideal he's
a human being like everyone else but as
I was mentioning run with this bubble
Hassan and morothy issue who has an
Ahmadi when I went to chef Robbie's
house with some brothers from America
and there were some brothers from his
students who were there one of those
brothers is my brother uncle eat Ibrahim
Smith who's been a teacher there in
Saudi Arabia for but what 2530 years
when I was staying in being as a
teaching he's still there it was one of
the brothers that was with me in the
mentions and we had left Medina and we
went to the Umrah and we met up with
chef Bobby in his house he let anybody
go but he kept us Danny gave us lunch
chef Lemmy told me why he denied a lot
he told me you are a pillar of asset
afiyah in the West you must go back and
warn against Al Hassan and modern mm-hmm
chef will be calling me a pillar of a
Santa Fe in the West you can't be the
imam of the jumpa the ideal making me
that pillow because I'm not at all upset
if he in the West so giving me that
statement if he really believed that if
he really believed that it's not true I
know that about myself and can't nobody
blow smoke in my ear or in my head to
make me feel bigger than what I hear he
said that to me and I don't accept it
because it angels natural the other
thing I mentioned was I think down in
the West year and as released I will
have said MonaVie this man has nothing
to do with my daughter my mother and my
father go far from the co far my family
members my community african-american
brothers and sisters in my community
therefore far those who are Muslims they
need to know about the Sunnah our
children are growing
and we have this issue of our children
leaving Islam and not practicing Islam
we have the government's where we come
from making policies trying to change
Norma to this land
pushing homosexual sexuality down the
throats of the people we have some
serious I had some serious issues here I
am NOT going back to give dower to Abu
Hassan Amata me they said no you must do
it because you are they broken from the
tower to center field the West must do
it have we went back and forth I'm not
doing that
that's not my daughter trying to impress
upon him this is craziness
I'm not doing something like that but I
saw that he was no someone he was
insistent persistent I said okay I have
a dish towel a bit of a problem and that
is we just came from a Medina and in
Medina I met up with your ship and my
ship we are we study time in that ship
so we have some chefs who have different
levels of students and that shape that I
was referring to was a chef up the
mousse and I'm not bad
I've hit one we were with him and I
asked him with the American brothers
what do you have to say about this war
that's going on with a shake of a B and
I will hustle MonaVie he said you people
should leave that and turn to beneficial
knowledge you should leave it and don't
worry about these things it only leads
to the hearts getting bad and so forth
so on I said so you're shipping out ship
a share of the lessons from our shield
this was his advice that we shall leave
it I should not talk about I was in
MonaVie but you're telling me I should
chef Rafi told me Allah he a ship of the
Mersenne doesn't read about these issues
and you read he doesn't know about Abu
Hassan my username I about Selma you
really you know mm-hmm thoughts about
personal experiences that let me say
that shekel it B is not the email of
chocolate ideal because if I share of
the Mersenne doesn't read and I will
salaries then woe unto pariah you know
read
we have the frigid NASA on reading if a
about the result up the
Machine and I bad better he doesn't read
and I will service reading then way ha
2l Kira LTI is done and those are the
experiences that I had my own
experiences so is this is it fair to say
that there were huge and conflicts
between these misciagna live chef Manabu
election honey which the students were
involved in and as a result of this we
find conflict within the followers of
the students in simple as that
no doubt it's as simple as that and what
happened was unfortunately I believe a
lot of people found that be a star to
shine and burn bright by taking on board
and making it their responsibility to
push the narrative of shaykh rabee those
people who support Chikara beach where
we raised them up so they a lot of
brothers who didn't study and I don't
have anything against people who didn't
study and a university because you can
be a person who has not stayed like the
young brother abdul rahman hassan abdul
rahman hassan abdul rahman hassan hasn't
really studied in the university as such
but he has more knowledge than most of
the people out there talking in my
opinion so I'm not against people within
study doesn't mean that inherently you
don't know what you're talking about but
when we see people who have not been
training they have not stayed at all we
see some of the mistakes and statements
of nonsense that they're making and some
of what they had to do with the
confusion of the fold that that's going
on that's looking the best blameworthy
that is blame rude
so what happened was the university of
johnny to the selenium medina is a
prestigious university just like them
and Egypt so if someone were able to
graduate from there it's going to give
him a level of respect and credibility
and if a person didn't graduate you may
not get that same level of respect so I
found that there were a group of
brothers who they didn't accomplish
graduating from in a university Davison
I will put each other yeah well yes
those people and what happened was they
took on board the battles of shaker beer
and then they raise the flag of and when
I want bara whatever position check for
B hell's you have to hold it and when he
didn't hold you can't hold it and
whatever you take this absent that we're
gonna wage or an issue that's matter it
shampo be raised up many of these people
which brings me to another very
important point about the Senate here
when I said that Senate fear is a
synonym for of Islamism in hydropower
process ma'am and it is alyssum and
Mustafa in a setting fear
Michael Islam you can't leave anything
out from this land that you are supposed
to practice so you can't cherry pick
this or that and leave it out I don't
want to wade each other I don't want to
pray I don't want to do this I want to
do that if it's magic you have to do it
if it's Haram you have to leave it alone
the point is it is not befitting for
believe in Mamo believing woman if a lot
its message to decide a thing that have
any say-so in that affair all right so
we can't leave anything about Alice lamb
out but let's say that a group of people
on set if he hill where everything that
there's for everything that they
think is correct you can't leave that
that's what they believe they believe
that they embody hell Islam with a
Sunnah now you have any right to say I
don't follow what ship rugby says in
that and I don't agree with what you're
saying in that and I am NOT leaving
anything off from Ellis lat
but when the person has a but not be as
understanding said if he is this and the
shape and body centered here and we
embody a said it via I said no that is
his penis that is an occult eye every
right to reject what you said what he
said I don't agree with your point of
view so I said if you have again it is
not what for Landsat or I'll and sad
this group of that group it is what the
Prophet SAW Allah I do subtle boy and
what those companions may allah be
pleased with them what they understood
and what they practice and that's why
there's a ship from saudi arabia and i
won't believe all ships are from saudi
arabia
his name is better than rotating better
and rotated the brother from Nelson a
lot bass and a bead those brothers
brought him here now remember defeating
those brothers with translating the fame
he has a beautiful clip that's been
translated on the internet when he was
saying what said in figure is and what
it is it and he was saying I said if he
is bill why he gained I said if he is
being kind to your guests as seven feet
is being clean as seven fee is being
merciful a son if he is all of that
asset if he is refuting people who
should be refuted in the way that they
should be refuted but said if he is not
all about reputation soon if he does not
me following your that's not safe
here
cause the question on this I was gonna
ask the question of for instance one of
the things that's happening now in the
West is that if there's a dire or a
public figures share poor scholar that
is seen sitting with someone who is not
seen as a Salafi say for example is a
Shiite or he is a Sufi or something of
that of that nature then they say that
person is now become a mocktail an
innovator where that happens on the one
hand there's also a contradiction in the
fact that we sometimes see general man
was telling himself some of the major
scholars of Saudi Arabia sin with
scholars who are also Sufi or she I
whatever so is there a big double
standard in the way there
by the principal's it is a major double
Stamper major double standard I actually
gave some words of advice to these
brothers and one of the words of advice
about six years ago in Ramadan was
called the double standards of SP that
double standards and I mentioned in
there how shameless lendable taymiyah
and his story in opium and other than
them they had showed how it is
permissible to cooperate with innovators
and non-muslims and evil people and evil
doers when you're doing something under
the umbrella of al-islam and only to be
accomplished by doing it in that way and
the harms don't outweigh the benefits
and so forth and so on and how the
shaykh rabee went to sue them and he sat
with the sufi xxx out of a sofia he sat
with them and he gave them down and
there's nothing wrong with that
how a ship will be in Saudi Arabia at
set and a meeting where their leader
called some of the Ghanim on some of the
shield some of the doctors some of
Islamic thinkers he told them what we
buddy to come together and we wanted to
address this issue about the identity
and preserving the identity of our
country our national our nationalism
ashecliffe he went to that he had to
obey the ruler but in that meeting were
people curse the companion self in that
meeting were people from the Shia and
that rule may not meet people from Sufis
because they represented all walks of
life of Saudi Arabia so he went and I
believe his participation in that was
under the umbrella of a sentence not to
be blamed for slaw yeah so when Shelby
does it it's okay when they do it it's
okay but how many Jack some brothers
were telling me about new mommy each
other and you know this is only my third
time meeting you don't sit with mommy he
job don't sit with my mini job why
shouldn't I sit with the brother because
of this is that well number one I didn't
see
and number two I'm gonna talk to him
about that and after I talk to you about
those things I am sitting with you I'm
silly because what I'm trying to do
overall I believe it I have a goal and
objective what I'm trying to do in terms
of making it clear to people hey this
extremism and might be as a problem
it is a problem because it is giving
people a misunderstanding about what
Sanofi it really is and there's another
issue that's really critical to Mattox
we are acting like what we call in
America the Keystone Cops back in the
days Laurel and Hardy the Three Stooges
way back in the day where they had
silent movies there are cops used to run
around looking for the criminal and they
would just move very very quickly
bumping into each other bumping into the
walls like clowns this is how we are
behaving you and I are going to hate
each other and be enemies to each other
because check or Abby doesn't like this
person of that person and based it on
that you and I are fighting each other
over those people you're going to scream
this the scene is the same now telling
it was not the sundeck by the word of
the cop and that's why that's why when
we find those people were with those
brothers I think they have about 30
people from their shifts and students
who have been thrown off of the midnight
balance brothers what kind of doll is
that what kind of doll is that one of
the things that made me also say
Schaeffler be is not I don't accept him
in the Imam of a judgment ideal is the
problem with Mohammed that you had in
much honey how many even know have you
met him he was singing the same tune of
shepper be well he shouldn't be likes he
likes he doesn't make it as a mic and I
remember he is about four five years ago
she flatly said home didn't know having
mockery is from the key bar and I
remember I heard that with my own ears
and I sold mine I was shocked and the SP
was saying the same thing when they
definitely got that chef Robi that was
his ruling
but some people were criticizing he said
it's from the major scholars that was
another thing when I heard I know Miami
didn't bill happy of my time he has
knowledge and I remember he was in my
focal t good at the dollar and we used
to love him because when he will come
for his class which always began after
the morning break like they call the
foot hop he would come in the third
period every day he would win his wish
he would have his phone that was halfway
to a sub and he would walk in there with
ASA and my Korea there were a lot of
people who are so lorries and incline
and stuff like that Eliezer jump died
all of the Muslims to the Sunnah and
bring us together on the hop and the
ship used to walk through and I used to
look at her - to save my shuttle life he
kind of beaten he gave this error
I don't care what you think and I like
that it wasn't arrogant I thought and I
felt it was the strength of the Sunnah
and one thing that I learned about him
is he is not a guest man you're not
gonna push him around
so now bad he broke away from but
be because he doesn't agree with some
people who share a be likes he doesn't
like them so he just thrown off of a set
of here
but anyway ashamed when Sharabi said
that he was a me just Staller I said man
come on man except that I studied in
sunny way I know the difference between
meter scholar and a student of knowledge
we are students of knowledge who are up
we are as a student knowledge was strong
a majors lunar knowledge there's a minus
term enough knowledge but from the keep
our dilemma now once they had a problem
now he's ignorant from the keyboard now
he's ignorant he is lazy doesn't that
books these are some of the reasons I
saved my own knives in my own ears I'm
an exception probably as being the Imam
of a jacket ideal doing our times nor do
I see him
as a person who as those brothers stay
with their Moodle we test people by
shaker beer and then taking the
statements of the set of matter context
we don't test people with chick rugby
what are you talking about but again
they get this stuff from people want
higher than them right because I'm happy
to have it much tougher yeah said anyone
anyone who goes to Mecca you don't go
see Sheikh for a beer
something's wrong with yourself either
that's extreme that is extreme and this
is what we've done we brothers come on
you have to get off of that stuff relax
and polish yourself you don't know
brother Muhammad hijab how many times I
have made a public attempt to invite
those brothers come come come let's come
to the table to discuss the situation
can you imagine I know that you do down
the people were atheist and so forth and
so on and atheist comes to you and says
listen Muhammad you Jack listen with all
sincerity I'm not here to argue with you
man I really want you to explain to me
how does a lie insist I'm gonna listen
would you let me say to another lap time
for you and I have time for you because
I have to eat lunch I'll have time for
you because you're not sincere I'll have
time for you because your visitor your
that would that be the response so we've
set to those brothers so many times
come come come I want to hear why i'ma
tell you I want to hear that we doing
the little I want to hear it
and if what you're saying is true I'm
gonna make tawba I'm gonna stop I'm
gonna do right thing yeah you know what
their response is yeah we don't sit with
the people bigger we don't sit with us
yes crazy right this is that my
sincerity can I ask a question on this
because do you think that they think
that they are more ahead that they for
example those people in sp
they're the main figures some someone
like Al Hadid you or someone like Bill
Davis or everywhere else and didn't feel
they do make them do they they have made
a deal myself
delfield admitted the army and his home
on his own without any scholars so the
question is what gives them the
confidence to be able to do that by
themselves I think it's a classic case
of what's been mentioned in the Quran
hmm like the statement we allowed Todd I
mentioned singing a shakedown alone so
I'm Annie
she thought maybe actions seem alluring
to that and okay and then we had that
other issue a little world war where a
person is impressed with himself I'm 70
we are the center few where the cream of
the crop and everybody else's off of it
we are therefore cut energy up and they
exist like that you don't see this level
of aiming slowed down pump your brakes
or slow down so just to summarize now I
mean what kind of advice would you give
people that are involved in this that
are in this kind of some really tragic
stories for example when we talk about
dr. Baker about literally families being
divided being broken up husband husband
being divorced my wife first they kept
happening because the person move today
we've heard real stories about you know
communities being broken up not just
families but the whole community be
broken up people sing Islam as an
intolerant religion because of this
group ISM the sectarianism what advice
would you give people that are involved
in this that might be benefiting from
this or how to get out of this well
first of all I think is really important
that we understand that the seraphic
community we do not have a monopoly on
trauma and misbehavior and things that
causes the eius to weep and the hearts
to become say all sects all groups have
the issues and the challenges but my
issue that we're dealing with right now
is just this thing where people are
talking as if they're the cream of the
crop and the laws give to the universe
and all this trouble that's being caused
brother so speaking to this narrative so
to answer that question there are three
types of people that I've found over the
years who have been able to navigate
through this thing properly three types
of people so a person has to be from two
of them at least the first person is the
one who has been impressed so the one
who tasted the oppression being looked
and say man this is not right
whether it's a man or woman people have
been impressed by that right and ready
hmm what happened with the people
already the way some of their brothers
were dealt with and the way they treated
people without giving them the benefit
doubt but the sad thing is that the
brothers have read it many times they
won't see that that's what they did to
other people the brothers were oppressed
by them in reading the way they were
dealt with and they don't like it then
the reading brothers are doing that with
other people so if you that's the
reading brother why is this brother tell
you that they don't know instead of
Parador the same garbage that they've
been hearing so people have been
impressed they know that it's not right
the second two things and this is my
fighting speed from these two people is
the person who is not a yes-man if
you're not a yes-man like the jagiya
your personality is you're not the type
of person people would come and push you
off the square and just because everyone
says that you're gonna get with the
program you make up your own mind you're
your own man because they put so much
pressure on people like I told you Musa
Richardson it gave my person email to
that because my problem with that and he
was my friend
and he subsequently became one of them
and when I talked about his people
skills that was back then definition now
so you can't be a yes-man I have always
told my students like musty mink when
they would say what they mean does this
movie make is that I said listen don't
let anybody push you and bully you into
a position for is people say what you
believe and then let the chips fall
where they went men the last person is
the one who has knowledge people are
basic now
No what they're doing is not right how
in the world can you force everybody to
take your position of for
disposition and if you don't take their
position then you're not on the sooner
you have to be boycotted you're to be
isolated and ostracized and marginalize
where does that come from a person who
has knowledge of this religion they'll
take those statements that they use from
the seller final context and say you
guys are using this out of context we
used to test the people with ahmed and
i'm edenian so what to do that we don't
sit with the people of innovation plus
the Senate then sit with people
innovation are you serious are you
really serious we can sit with people of
innovation but there are a lot of it
there are rules and regulations so my
advice get knowledge and be a man be a
man a person who has who would did to
have your own position and electric
position be known and if you want to
stay under the radar so that's the drama
passes you by
I don't blame you this is the timeless
fitting so if a person doesn't want to
get involved in the drama and I respect
that don't get involved but be quiet and
don't impress people just because they
were oppressing them by dr. Lamas
crusade he said that the corner in math
don't be a copycat if the people do
right you do right the people do wrong
you do wrong he said the thing but
you try to use your brain if the people
drank the right with that but the people
be wrong you don't do wrong with it
that's my point I was summer 30 it's
been a pleasure talking to you today
my pleasure acting mahamuni jab I said
laying equal Mubarak or my feet happy
and that is another interview of done
with one of the forerunners of this
selfie now are you in the United Kingdom
in cello you've benefited from this with
said I wanna cancel are you wearing it